at this point it's on I'm going to place
you under arrest for uh murder times two
okay you remain on the course and
actually you didn't have to say anything
this is Jamie Barrow being arrested on
suspicion of starting a fire that killed
his neighbors
one-year-old Nema and her three-year-old
sister Fatima died in The Blaze their
mother Fatima haidara passed away in
hospital days later the night before
Jamie Barrow had been drinking he was
seen buying beer then captured heading
home
four hours later he would start the fire
this is what people on the street in
Nottingham woke up to smoke billowing
from the first floor window firefighters
were trying to save the family inside
moments after the fire took hold Jamie
Barrow was seen on CCTV walking away but
returned a short time later to ask
police how bad it was
because she already grabbed your details
smiling at offices as he answered their
questions he later rang police to ask
when he could get back into his flat
how can I help
hello my name's Jamie I live on the Fair
Isle place at number 19.
um whether next to where the fire was
earlier this morning yeah
and this one's really doing any update
on whether I'm alive I can profit my
prophecy or not the husband and father
of the victims have been in America at
the time he flew home as soon as he
heard the news by then his girls were
dead and his wife was in hospital
have to go and see her right I mean I
have no idea what went wrong I just we
were just coming from London and I
figured we're coming
Barrow who has a personality disorder
admitted putting petrol through the door
and lighting it with tissue paper but
said he didn't think his neighbors were
in he said he'd lit fires before to
release stress claiming it mesmerizes
him his actions robbed a family of a
mother and her daughter's young lives so
senselessly cut short